creating a user interface for your
machine learning model can make it
easier to adjust the model and visualize
the results gradio is a python library
that makes it super easy for machine
learning engineers to create intuitive
user interfaces in this course abdul
will teach you all aspects of gradio
including deployment
dear fellow coders welcome to one little
coder radio machine learning app course
2021 i welcome you to this course and in
this course you will learn the fastest
way to demonstrate your machine learning
model using gradio gradio is a python
library and we are going to learn more
about gradio in this course follow us on
youtube to learn more about machine
learning data science and analytics
this course contains nine sections and
this course runs about one hour 15
minutes let's get started understanding
what is this course content the first
thing is you will learn what is the
current problem that we have in the ml
prototyping space
and then you will learn about advantages
of cradio and what is gradio
next you will learn how to get started
with gradio with a very simple example
to create your first radio web
application
and next there are a lot of different
components of radio so you have
component for image you have component
for text you have different components
and in this section you will learn the
different components of radio
and in the next section you will learn
how to handle multiple inputs and
multiple outputs in a typical radio
application
and next you will learn about debugging
your radio application and also using a
very special feature that radio has got
called flagging
and next you will learn how to improve
your radio applications user interface
and user experience this section will
also help you understand how can you
change the theme and also have your own
style in your video application
and next you will learn how to share the
gradient application with everybody in
the world and also how to add security
which means add an authentication layer
at the top so that only people whom you
want to check the gradient application
can check
and finally we are going to finish this
course with a capstone project where we
are going to build a gradient
application that is powered by deep
learning and that deep learning powered
gradio application we will learn how to
deploy it on hugging face spaces so
starting from understanding the space to
completely deploy this application on a
permanent hosting you will learn
everything from scratch to end to end in
this one hour 50 minutes course which is
about nine sections if you do not have
time for all the nine sections of this
course what i've done here is at this
this particular page you can actually
see that there are certain things those
have been highlighted and those
highlighted things are the most
important thing if you only cover these
important things you will be able to
build a decent radio application so if
you do not have time for everything else
you can at least go fast track with
these highlighted items and that will
give you the necessary knowledge to
build a gradient application
which you can use to demonstrate your
machine learning model let's get started
with the course and i hope you will find
this course valuable
in this section we'll learn a little bit
about the challenges that we have in
building a machine learning web
application especially for prototyping
so if you go to google and then say
machine learning web app
using
then you would suddenly see a lot of
suggestions like flask is there you've
got stream literature you've got
django's there so you've got all these
suggestions there so the first problem
that you usually face when you want to
build a machine learning web application
for prototyping let's say or even i can
say that machine learning machine
learning web app prototype
web app using
yeah
so if you say this thing now you would
you'd see a lot of lot of suggestions
uh flask is there again the extreme
latest there you would see django
somewhere so the first problem that you
have is
what is the solution that i should pick
for my current need and it could be
anything right so you have solutions
varying from flask to django to
streamlight and a lot of other solutions
exist in this space especially in recent
times if you see
a lot of new applications or libraries
that helps
that that is there to create web
application around your machine learning
or data science model so for example
solutions like for example if i go
online and then look for streamlit
versus flask
versus then you see django dash then
versus then you see gradient so
basically if you see the current space
you have all these different python
libraries that is there to create
that is there to help you create a web
application around your machine learning
solution so it is very important for you
to understand what is the problem that
we have in the current space the problem
that we have in the current space is
that
you have either applications like
flask
which is usually used for a full stack
web application using python ecosystem
flask or jungle for that matter or you
have something like streamlight which is
which is again a very good
application or library for you to create
ml web application or even any web
application of that
sort you can even build a streamline
dashboard analytical dashboard
and you can you can do everything with
streamlit but you don't need the level
of knowledge of flask or django because
streamlit helps you wrap around all the
important components in the form of
stimulator and you have got stimulated
but components so now when you see a
world where you've got stream rate and
where you've got flask and django now
you would start wondering what is the
one that i need to pick
and because this course is about gradio
i would like to highlight where does
gradio fit in this stack
so if you see like let's go to the
examples available on hugging face
spaces so this is hugging face spaces
where we have got a bunch of
applications available okay so now when
you go to spaces and then look for one
of the most popular spaces like these
are the spaces of the week so if i look
at one of the most popular spaces when i
click it
it's loading
and you can you can actually see a
gradient application popping up so this
is this is built with gradient so you
have an input text and then you need you
can you can do anything like
multi-lingual summarization model and
then you have the ability to select
languages
and then you have an output designed
so this is the typical use case where
you want to use gradient over any other
solution
so
my pitch here is
let's say you want to build a startup
and that startup should have
like high ability and then you want
like a prediction grade application not
now now this is the time probably you
would start using
flask or django because that's what
people do so you have a flask developer
a jungle developer and then you put
together full stack development team and
then you can start protectionizing your
web application
let's say like you are building the next
facebook next google or whatever the
next is right
if you are in that condition if you are
in that state
then you know
for the web application that we are
talking about
for the machine learning powered web
application that we are talking about
you need a solution
that is quite scalable
that can handle a lot of different
things not just only machine learning
but you know a lot of different things
so you would probably go with flask or
django
and let's say like you are in a space
where your solution is very confined to
machine learning
especially data science machine learning
you want to build dashboard you want a
tableau alternative um you want easy
wrappers around machine learning you
want like simple third-party components
i would probably prefer to go with
streamlid there streamlit is highly
flexible i love streamlate and streamlet
also makes it easier for you to deploy
okay so this is where stream letter
now in this process in this entire
process
let's say you want to build an mvp what
is an mvp mvp stands for minimum viable
product
this is a product that you would build
to gain your customer confidence to find
out product market fit
to find out whether this is a product
that people want to use
that is an mvp
the second thing is while your machine
learning team is creating models you
want to make sure that you have the best
model in place
you have the best in class state of the
art model that is available for your
customer
so you which means you're going to build
a lot of models like you're going to do
an experiment probably ways and biases
comment neptune whatever solution that
you use for experiment but at the same
time you also want somebody to actually
play with the model that you have built
so now we are talking about two cases
one you want to build an mvp minimum
viable product for your startup or
second you want to build a web
application that is used for iterating
your machine learning solution
now if you are in this situation either
of these situation i would strongly
recommend using radio because radio is
specially built for this purpose or at
least in my opinion like you could talk
to gradius founder and then probably
that person might have a different
opinion but if you ask me
if you look at gradeo
if you are in a corporate setup or if
you are a hobby hobbyist mission
hobbyist
or if you are somebody who is trying to
build
a web application or like a machine
learning startup like you could be an
entrepreneur you could be in academia
you could be a normal data centers like
typical data scientist like me or you
could be a hardcore machine learning
engineer who is working for
facebook artificial intelligence
research or google brain or some kind of
organization you could be any of these
things
now one of the things that you would do
across all these different verticals is
that you need to iterate on your machine
learning application
you need to build an mvp before your
startup looks you know like goes big so
in that case i would strongly prefer
radio because radio gives me that
flexibility to build something like very
fast very soon without having to be
worried about you know scalability
without having to be worried about
deployment without having to be worried
about what is the css style looks like
what is the style uh how do i have to
change my you know style like what how
does the head headliner take should look
like i don't have to be worried about
any of these things because this is the
phase where i'm going to if i'm if i'm
an entrepreneur i'm going to probably
focus on you know finding the product
market fit making more people use my
product and finding how they feel about
it like how they feel about the solution
or if i'm in academia or if i'm in like
building machine learning solution i
would be probably more interested in
finding the best model that i can serve
my customers with
so if you are caught in this situation
so you're not building the next facebook
you're not building the next twitter you
are not even you know building an
analytics dashboard
if you are in this situation but still
you want a web application that is to be
created fast that is to be created and
shared with everybody and that also has
you know some flexibility to deploy
permanently then i would
like completely support picking up
gradio for this purpose because i
strongly feel
radio is used for this purpose so if you
come across a question like gradient
versus streamlined versus flask versus
django anywhere on the internet
then probably my take on that is you
have to use different
products different libraries for
different stages of your product life
cycle if you are not a pruner so if you
are in an mvp face i would close my eyes
and then pick radio
if you are on a phase where i'm going to
deploy my production grade machine
learning solution i would probably go
with um
if if it is only a machine learning
solution but only machine learning
solution probably i would go with
streamlight again like slightly an
enhanced version of um
mvp but if you want like a production
grade solution like let's say i'm
building the next facebook or twitter
something then i would probably go with
django something that this people uh
something that these people usually use
for production grade web application
something that can compete with the
javascript ecosystem so this is how i
usually see this problem but you can see
the natural problem that we have here
the problem that we have here is
not
about which solution to pick but
generally if you want to build a web
application you don't want like you
don't want web public building a web
application to be an overhead for your
current problem so your current problem
is solving a machine learning problem
and you have to just solve that you
cannot sit and spend your time on
learning how to you know connect your
apis within java like a flask you cannot
you cannot think about how to you know
get your app router to particular link
you cannot do all those things
these are like roadblocks these can
inhibit your progress in your machine
learning research or application or
whatever you do right whether it is
machine learning research or applied
machine learning you don't want a
solution that can stay in your way
prohibiting inhibiting your progress and
doing something greater than just
building an application you want a
solution that should make it much much
easier just like icing on the cake
to enable you build a web application
that can help you serve your web
application
sorry that can help you serve your
machine learning solution as a web
application that the entire world can
use i would strongly pick radio so if
you are wondering
why gradio
then you do you have the answer in this
video which is to say that i would pick
radio whenever i want to show machine
learning demo whenever i want people to
use my models whenever i want to build
an mvp and whenever i want
people to actually you know play with
the model and iterate on it and then
finalize the best solution so internal
or external customer facing or internal
you know like machine learning engineers
iterating whatever this is this is a
place where i would probably pick radio
over any other existing solution because
every solution has its own place in the
machine learning life cycle or product
development life cycle so for this
particular phase i would prick radio and
then we will learn more about gradio as
well in this course
a quick introduction to gradio what is
gradio gradio is the fastest way to demo
your machine learning model with a
friendly web interface so that anybody
can use it anywhere in the world so
gradua has this pitch that says build
and share delightful machine learning
applications with anybody in the world
and what does it mean
it means
if you have to demo demonstrate your
machine learning model you don't have to
create a full stack web application
rather what you can do is you can wrap
your function with gradeo and then
gradio would be able to create a web
interface for you as you can see in the
screen it says with five lines of pure
python code you should be able to create
a ui around your machine learning
application let's look at the example
here so let's look at the sketch
recognition so you've got handwriting
recognition machine learning model or
sketch recognition machine learning
model and then you want to create a web
application around it for people to use
it for people to experience how good
your machine learning model is it could
be either you are creating a demo for
somebody else or it could be that you
want to yourself check the validity of
your machine learning model
the efficiency of your machine learning
model so for you to do all these things
if you have a web application that you
can play around with that is a great
great way for you to learn how your
model is performing and usually
typically it's not an easy task for you
to do and radio makes it really really
easy if you see this code here for
sketch recognition the first step is
import the library
then wrap your sketch recognition model
everything within a function
and use that function as a gradient
interface and the input in your image
you can see that the input image which
is the input for the function it's been
given as an input image here and then
output you're going to label the output
like the display the output so let's go
ahead and then try to use this
application and then see how it works so
you have got a canvas here
and this canvas
has
a
an attached output so you have an input
and you have an output so let me clear
this and then you can see there is like
there is nothing here right so i am
going to clear this and then say
three okay this looks like three yeah
you can see that it has gone into the
machine learning model and the machine
learning model has tried to figure out
what is this and then it has given you
the output score
so this is the easiest way let me let me
write something very ambiguous okay so
i'm going to write like this okay it's
for not very ambiguous so if i do like
this
yeah so now you know it doesn't know
whether i'm trying to write 9 or 6 or 4
whatever it is right so this is how you
can actually see okay where are the
places your machine learning model is
not doing good and then you can probably
fix that and that is that is one of the
advantages of using radio because gradio
lets you do that with a very very simple
interface all you have to do is wrap
around your machine learning functions
whatever you're doing within within a
like main function
here sketch recognition and use that
function as an input to the radio
interface so that is your input
and all you have to do is import the
gradient library and like that you can
see couple of other examples that is
there on the website question and answer
you so you have got the question so the
idea here is that you can use it for um
computer vision task just like this you
can use it for nlp tasks like a question
and answer generation you can use it for
a speech recognition like you can speech
detection and translation text to speech
speech to text and also if you want to
you know mark some
mark some like um segmentation within
your image you can still do that so
these are like all the examples and the
one thing that common you would see
across all these examples is that you
import the library you wrap it around
the function and then you have the
gradient interface sketch recognition
question and answer and everything you
would see the same thing it might be
that you know the number of inputs
differ like for example in this case
you've got two inputs right but but the
fundamentals are same you do the same
thing and then it just helps you create
that interface okay so now we know that
radio is an application like a python
library that can help you
create
easy web interfaces for your machine
learning model that could be shared with
anybody let's look at some of the
companies that are using radio so if you
see the logos that are available here
you can actually see that almost all
reputed companies that use machine
learning model you can see like google
is there amazon is there facebook is
there you can call it meta whatever you
want cisco is there hugging faces there
vmware siemens like all these companies
and also educational institutes like mit
and stanford all of them are using radio
so this is again for you to gain a
confidence that this solution is there
to exist it's not a solution you know
that's by that is just used by a bunch
of hobbyists gradeo is a solution that
is being used at corporate level and
academic level and it is a way forward
for you to demonstrate your machine
learning model if you are not using
radio
so what are the advantages of using
radio
so first of all gradient is quite easy
and fast to set up
all you have to do is install radio and
you all know like um if you're in the
python ecosystem you know that all you
have to do is pick install gradient and
creating a gradient interface requires
only a couple of lines of python code to
your existing project which means you
don't have to change a lot of things in
your code existing code because that
shouldn't the objective of creating a
user interface for your machine learning
model
shouldn't
shouldn't be a roadblock in your machine
learning itself so that's the whole
point of gradient right so it's that you
just have a machine learning model and
all you wanted to do is create a ui now
you don't have to deal with you know a
lot of aps you don't have to deal with a
lot of new classes and a lot of new
libraries the whole advantage and the
point objective of graduate is that you
keep your machine learning code as it is
and all you have to do is add a couple
of lines of python code like pure python
code
and then that entire script is now
turned into a ui user interface that
anybody can play with so so that's
that's the greatest thing so fast and
easy setup that's a very good advantage
that you've got the first
the next thing is
you can present this
as part of a lot of things for example
you can present this as part of your
jupyter notebook
or python notebook to be precise because
now you have got a lot of different
notebooks right uh zeppelin notebook
jupyter notebook vs code notebook so you
can present it as notebooks like embed
within notebook or you can also present
it as a separate web page so you have
the liberty for example if you're
prototyping something on a google collab
notebook you can still
create a gradient interface within a
google collab notebook and gradio will
give you a url which you can use
to embed this gradient ui the web
application within your google collab
notebook which means let's say you're
going to publish a paper
right so what is what what is papers
with code so you try to publish your
paper with the code but imagine you can
publish your paper not just with code
but also with a web interface where
people can play around with your model
like now this is going to prevent a lot
of things for example
let us say there is a bias in your model
and then you have no clue about the bias
but before the model becomes mainstream
somebody plays around with that and then
come up with the bias like identify the
bias
and you can you can actually see a lot
of people have utilized radio to find
such biases available in image
segmentation model language
language models in the past about a
particular community so graduate has
been already used where biases have been
identified
the second thing is adversarial attacks
when you have a machine learning model
you want to make sure that you know the
models
are not going to be attacked by you know
some some silly examples or
some like it's it's not prone to
adversarial attack so for that you
cannot make sure everything and then you
know the community can always help you
and for that again like if you have your
model
and you believe it's a very good model
you believe it can do something good in
the world it's it's a it's very
important for you to make sure
what kind of adversarial attacks this
model is prone to and for somebody to
actually even try out that adversarial
attack
they need something to play with right
and radio can be that
so gradio could be embedded within your
collab code google notebook sorry google
collab notebook jupiter notebook or any
sort of python notebook and also as a
separate web page so you can just take
the link and then share it with anybody
like it generates a public link for you
and then you can generate it with
anybody imagine imagine like you are
you're
trying to attend a
machine learning interview and you have
been asked to build a model and then
instead of just rather giving just a
model and like pickle file you can
actually build an interface and then
share it with your potential employer or
you're going to go to a conference and
then you want to you want to show
something out of your machine learning
and instead of having the machine
learning model on your powerpoint
presentation you can also have it as a
web interface where all the attendees in
the conference can play with so this is
enormous potential and that's the second
biggest advantage of radio like you you
can present and share radio applications
within notebook outside of notebook with
anybody in the world
another third thing is if you want to do
permanent hosting like until now we were
talking about temporary hosting you get
a you get like a url that is like an
ngrok url and then you can share it with
anybody but but if you want permanent
hosting
today you have a very good option which
is called hugging face spaces so hugging
face spaces is an initiative from
hugging face the machine learning
company that used to be the nlp company
where you can deploy your gradient
interface for completely free very easy
very simple i've got a separate video
about that already i can link that in
the youtube description but otherwise
you can also
check it out at the end of this course
we will learn how to deploy a gradient
ui grade your app on hugging face spaces
like even without even touching your
local mission completely coded on
the web and also deployed deployed
completely like seamlessly and the
workflow is really really easy so if you
want permanent hosting again you have a
very good option in the form of hugging
face spaces
to host your grady application now that
url you could share it with anybody you
can
i mean you you can now share it with
anybody permanently not just like a
temporary interface so easy and fast
setup you can present and share the
gradient application with anybody in the
form of notebook or web application and
finally you have the ability to
permanently host gradient applications
these are these are really good
advantages and like i said before um
letting people to play around with your
model has a lot of advantages in a
corporate world and also in an academia
um one is like i said like you can
eliminate bias you can eliminate
adversarial attacks second is like you
can actually let people play around with
something that you have built which is
the whole point of building something
right so a lot of advantages of using
radio gradient has very good interface
with hugging phase jupyter notebook
matplotlib numpy torch scikit-learn and
a lot of other machine learning
libraries are scientific stack and
python
and you can see already there are a lot
of people who love using radio and then
they have windows radio to
to use radio as a solution to do a lot
of things for example if you see the
last example it very clearly says uh
honestly without radio we wouldn't be
doing a real time a trial so in clinical
trials for them to try out their
algorithm
they have used cradio and like without
nlp again somebody has used radio and
you can you can actually see a lot of
different use cases of how people have
used gradient what all the things that
people have used radio for
so
if you are interested in taking your
machine learning model and then making a
full stack application this course is
for you so we'll learn more about gradio
in the future section
in this section we're going to learn how
to build our first gradeo application
previously we learned about why do we
need gradeo and what is gradio and some
of the advantages of gradio and so here
we're going to start with coding and to
code i'm going to basically use the
getting started page on gradeo this is
quite a comprehensive page if you don't
prefer watching a video i would strongly
recommend you to check out this page
so to code i'm choosing google collab
interface so i've created a google
collab notebook so all you have to do is
go to in go to google and then type
google collab you would get an interface
and you have to go to file and click new
notebook
once you click new notebook you would
get something like this and then you can
change the name of the notebook so i
have given the name here called building
your first radio web application
let me zoom it zoom it a little bit so
that you can see it
after you have all these things you can
connect with the google collab notebook
basically google collab notebook is a
google machine that google gives us to
practice machine learning like create
applications whatever like create
scripts whatever you want and this is a
notebook interface hosted on google
collab so at this point you can see like
you've got a machine like you've got a
decent machine and you can see the
machine's usage here like the ram and
disk all these things for our purpose
you can do the same thing on your local
machine as well you don't you don't
necessarily need google cloud but if you
need google collab you can use that as
well so the first step after you have
the google collab interface is basically
you will have certain basic python
libraries that are predominantly used in
python machine learning stack
for
just just by default for example if you
want pandas you would already have
pandas here but if you want something
that is not available there then you
need to you need to imp you need to
install the library first so in our case
we are going to install gradu
first the first step is install
gradients so i'm going to say
pip
let me delete this
now to say pip
install gradient so first step is
install the library gradient
and you can you can see that it is
getting started
if you face any issue in this basically
all you have to do is go here and then
just restart runtime
yeah restart runtime after you restart
runtime you can see the runtime gets
restarted
and after the runtime is restarted you
would see it being connected to a
machine so this
this icon would change like from orange
so you are getting a new mission
allocated
after this allocation you can again
install the library so whenever you face
an issue on google collab all you have
to do is go there and then restart your
runtime but make sure if you have
anything temporary like a temporary
variable store when you restart runtime
it may not be available for you
so let's wait for the machines
allocation to happen so the first
application that we are going to build
would something look like this so you
give a name and then it would give an
output and then i'm going to explain you
every single part of the code so that
that's going to be this particular
section where you would get to learn the
gradio
web application
once your connection is established you
can see this here then all you have to
do is go ahead and then install the
gradient library
at this point the gradual library would
get installed it's a very lightweight
library so it shouldn't take a lot of
time for you to
install
so you can see that the gradient library
has been successfully installed
so after the library is installed um you
can you can basically like um just for
the sake of sanity i'm going to clean my
outputs but yeah you can just keep it as
well or you can install it quietly like
this so after the radio library is
installed the next thing that we're
going to do is we're going to build our
first application so the first thing
that we have to do as in every python
library is import gradio as jia so
you're basically importing the gradio
library here with the alias gr the next
thing that you have to do is you need a
function so
a gradio
interface has three components a
function input and output so first we
need to define the function
so let's say we need to define a
function that says hello world okay very
typical machine learning stuff um
programming so where we are going to
return um saying
hello
and
it's probably an emoticon plus
the name
the name okay so this is what we are
going to do and maybe like if you want
we can we can add something to this so
this is your function if you want to see
how the function works what you can
start doing is you can call the function
and then you know pass on some name
maybe you can say
little coder and then see whether it
outputs okay it outputs hello one little
encoder so let's let's give some space
so that we have this thing so now our
function is said that
the function main function that you want
to create assume that this is your
machine learning model right now you
don't have a machine learning model but
it's like you know you could be you
could have a speech translation model
some machine learning model so now that
you have got your
function now let's start building our
gradient interface so the gradient
interface we want to like you can call
it anything you can like i can just call
it interface so i can say interface is
equal to
i can say gr dot interface
and within this i'm going to have three
main components one is a function sorry
did i just call it wait
yeah uh one is a function
the function what we want to call here
is hello world and the second thing is
an input
so what kind of input do we want do we
want to capture a text input because
that's what we're doing here right so
text another third is output and what
kind of output we want we want the text
output so text input
text output
and also what is the function so now
let's define this interface
okay hello world is not defined
it's because i've made a stupid typo
okay hello world is defined
and then we have got the interface now
that this is successfully run the next
step for us is to launch the interface
interface
launch and once you launch the interface
ideally you should be able to see the
application
somewhere here so let's wait for it to
launch so couple of things would happen
behind the scene so google collab
notebook
if you want um if you want
if you want the notebook to show
like if you want to debug so you need to
use debug is equal to true while
launching you have a public url as well
so this link will expire in 72 hours so
if you want if you want longer links
probably you need to contact radio
support which is not required for us and
then also like you have you have the app
okay so let's click the link
then go here and see how does it look
like
it's loading as you can see
and we have the same application
embedded here as well so we can see the
same thing here as well so you can see
that you have the name and
you have the output so let's say i want
to give one little coder
and submit this and then you can see
hello and little quota if i say hello
python with an emoticon
maybe i can face emoticon and then
submit so you get this so basically you
have something you submitted and while
it is run you can see you can see
something happening here click this you
can see you can see that right so you
can see that this is being processed and
then you can you can take a screenshot
if you want to flag it you can do you
can do all these things if you want to
clear this input you can clear this
input so these are like the basic
default
options that you get with radio but
again this is not what
intel gradius and the same application
whatever we just opened with the url
like so the url is useful for you to
share it with your friends and potential
employer colleagues like whatever
whoever is on the world of the planet
with internet connectivity but if you
want to share this web application as a
google collab notebook or a jupyter
notebook or any notebook of that sort so
you can still do it because the same
thing is also embedded here so i can go
here and then say um
radio
okay and i can put put some
magic
and when i click submit so you can see
that it has taken
0.00 seconds like very cl very minimal
time and then you can see the output as
well and if i want to take a screenshot
of this i can take a screenshot of this
so at this point we have successfully
managed to build our very first gradient
web application and in the next section
we will learn
how to improve this web application is
this is this enough for our let's say
computer vision problem no this is not
enough is this enough where we need to
have multiple input options no this is
not enough so the next section we're
going to learn the customizations of
different components that are available
in grade u but at this point you should
be able to code your very first gradient
web application so congratulations to
you
in this section you're going to learn
how to customize radio components which
means in the last section you learned
how to build a very simple gradie
application and this section will help
you to improve or enhance your
application for your needs so if you
remember what we learned in the last
section a gradient interface a gradient
application the interface the core
interface class it actually has three
main parameters one is a function the
function is where the input
is passed on to and the output of the
function whatever you're returning from
the function is shown as an output and
if you remember that's what you have so
you have got the input and you have got
the output and something goes between it
that is the function so now we are going
to learn and finally right of course
after you do all these things you're
going to launch so
basic the basic skeleton of of a
gradient application is you have the
import statement you have the function
then you have the interface then finally
you're going to launch
now we are going to learn how to
customize these components like input
output
or also anything else that is available
in such a way that you can build
slightly more complex applications
because that's the whole point right
nobody is going to just take a text and
then show something i mean like you can
build radio applications like that as
well but our whole point is to do
something beyond this and then we can
see we can learn how gradio supports us
or enables us doing that thing and once
again like i said in the previous video
i'm basically using the material the
code that is available in the gradient
documentation i strongly recommend you
using this documentation so if you have
any like if you have any concern
whatever i am showing on the video you
should definitely refer the
documentation because that is exactly
what i'm using as well so let us get
started and then try to understand how
to customize our radio component so
currently our radio application looks
like this so we have a name
and we have an output okay so there is
one name and one output
like right now you can see the text box
is not very big what if you need a
bigger text box
a very valid question right so what if
you need a bigger text box all you have
to do is you have to create an input
component so i'm just copying the same
radio interface that we already had and
instead of
creating a new function i'm just going
to show you like we can keep the same
function which is the hello world in
this case but i'm going to show you how
you can change the input so what we are
trying to do is we are trying to make
this input slightly bigger and for that
we are going to use a new component from
gradio which is
gradient because we have imported
gradeos
and gr
gradio inputs so we have inputs and
within that you can see you have a lot
of inputs like you have audio checkbox
data frame drop down so you have a lot
of things and then the one that we are
interested in is we're going to use a
text box and the text box takes an
argument that says lines number of lines
so let's say we want a five line and
then we can have a placeholder text the
placeholder text is enter your input
here to the data and then
we can now execute this and then say
interface dot launch
and you should oh did i just yeah that's
my plan
and then you can launch the interface
like you can see the interface now you
can see there is a different url
altogether but you can launch so now you
have a bigger name so instead of had
having a smaller name so if you want
this to be more like a lot bigger then
you can again change the number of lines
and then you can have a bigger text box
so this is how you can customize the
input okay so you had function we kept
the same function you had output we kept
the same output but we just changed the
input from a simple text box like a
single line text box into multi-line
text box that gives us multiple lines of
the code so this way this is a simple
example for you to learn
how to change the gradient components
like how to change the gradient
component within the gradient
application so that you can have
multiple
lines of input text given that this is a
text let us say we don't want text okay
let's say we don't want text but we want
an image so in the next section we'll
learn how to
build
an image input instead of text input
we'll learn how to build an image input
and that image input
will be used for some kind of machine
learning once again so for that let's go
to the gradient documentation and there
is a very nice example that that is
given we're going to take the same
example and then i'm going to show you
i'm going to explain you the components
so import gradios gr same thing numpy is
for image processing we are just going
to apply a sepia filter okay so we are
going to take an input image and then we
are going to apply a sepia filter and
then that's a
let's let's leave this function because
this is just going to apply this api
filter so the most important part for us
is instead of having a text like as in
here
which is
which is here right instead of having a
text box we are going to have an image
as an input and then we are also giving
the shape of the image okay and the
output is also supposed to be an image
and once you run this
you can see
the
you can see the text box like ideally
the box so you can click and upload it
or you can drop down the image so if you
have downloaded the image somewhere then
you can drop drop down drop the image
here and then that will work so i can i
can show you a sample image and then we
can see how it works
so i've selected an image from my folder
and you can see the image is available
so i'm going to click submit
and then you can see that the cpi filter
has been applied so basically instead of
having a text input you're getting an
input image and also the output format
is an image so again this is not named
argument like if you want named again
you can say my function is equal to this
my input is equal to this my output is
equal to this but if you don't want that
to happen like if you just want to just
want to give this like in the same order
you can do the same thing as well like
you have the gradient interface your
function your input and output and in
this case image is not input is not text
but it is an image and you get that from
inputs class so inputs image and then
output is also image so we have
successfully learnt in this section we
have successfully learned how to use
radio
to build an image application like an
application that takes image as an input
and also
image as an output
so now that this this is quite
interesting right so we first saw text
we then saw image but now the question
is what if
we want to work with tabular data so in
the next section we're going to learn
how to build a gradient application that
takes tabular data as an input and once
again like i said we're going to refer
the gradio
documentation so gradient documentation
has a very nice example where you work
with
tabular data so there is a tabular data
and that tabular data has been taken
inside and then you know some kind of
data transformation and not not to the
etl level but some data transformation
is happening and then you can see there
is an input data frame so there is a
data frame as input so this is again
used just for an example but you could
you could be reading the data frame from
your csv file and you could be
displaying as well
but the important thing that you have to
note here is you have an input component
called data frame so like you had text
box like you had image now you have an
improved uh format called data frame and
also output so you have like data frame
as an output you have plot and you have
numpy so you have input and you have
output and you have the function and we
can add a description as well so this is
something that we have not seen before
where we didn't see description but we
have seen a description so let's launch
it
once again it's loading and then you can
see
that you have you have an input data
frame if you click submit
you can see output one is a table so you
can see you can go to the function and
see it's returning three things one you
are returning a tabular data frame
second you are returning a plot and
third you are returning a numpy array so
you have an output
you have a plot and then you have a
numpy array so if you want to change the
value again like go ahead and then just
change something run it and then you
would see like again ideally in an ideal
world you would not define the data
frame as it is probably you would be
loading a csv file or something and
that's what like when you load a csv
file if you have a different value click
submit and then you have three outputs
output one output to output three so you
have three outputs if you again if you
want to change it let's say like you
don't want the outputs you just want to
plot we can go here delete whatever we
are returning
and then we can come back here also
delete the output format so we have only
plot here and then run this again
when you once you run this thing you
would have only the input and output and
then once i click submit you can see the
output chart itself so again you are not
specifying where the output should be
shown so if you had noticed when we had
more than one input um sorry when we had
more than one output gradient itself
managed to display output one by one but
typically if you're building an
application
using any other existing tool so you
have to manage that you have to manage
how this switch so you have to manage
whether it is a response or not but here
you don't have to be worried about it
once again you have the output here if
you want to change again you can change
again like we saw before if you want to
take a screenshot you can take a
screenshot or right click and save the
image like whatever you want to do you
can basically do and this is how exactly
you have
an input data frame you have an input
data frame and you have an output plot
as a chart
okay so so far
in the previous sections we have learnt
input text
input
image and now we learned about input
data frame and that's quite helpful so
these these are the three main formats
that typically a data scientist or
machine learning engineer would be using
again you can have audio right so uh the
the potential is enormous like you if
you want audio
all you have to do is go here
uh let's say
inputs and you can see you can see audio
so you can have audio as well like you
can have audio and a lot of other things
but if you ask uh like a typically
machine learning engineer or a data
scientist image text and these are like
a few valuable let me
a few valuable
things a few valuable formats tabular
format image and text of a few valuable
formats that typically data centers
mission learnings use a lot so we have
learned how to create a gradient
application text application how to
create a gradient image application and
also how to create a gradient
application that takes a tabular data as
an input so
now we have explored different
components like image text and tab um
data frame in the next section we are
going to learn how to use this different
components and also have different kinds
of input and
more than that so let's see in the next
section how to use multiple inputs and
outputs in your gradio application
so far in the previous sections we
learned how to build a simple gradient
web application we also learned about
customizing components like different
formats exploring different formats like
image
text
and tabular data so in this section we
are going to learn
how to use multiple inputs not different
types of inputs but multiple inputs so
not every time you want to use only the
same input right so for example if you
see here you have one text box if you
see this example you have a bigger text
box and if you see this example you have
got one image but what if you are in a
situation where you need to take
multiple input from the user and you
want to process it in such a way and
then give some output so for that what
we're going to do is we're going to make
a simple function just like a hello
world example and then we are also going
to learn how to handle multiple inputs
in a gradient application once again
like i say in every section you can
always explore the documentation for
this part and it is quite comprehensive
and
the examples that i've taken for this
code is again from the documentation
so let's start from scratch if you have
not even you know seen that whatever we
did before so we are importing radio as
gr so that part is done so the next
thing is we need to create a function we
need to create a function that can do
something so what we can do in this case
is we can say let's calculate bmi okay
um i don't i don't necessarily know the
formula for bmi but i'm just going to
take a shot
bmi
and let's say we want to take bmi for a
person
and then we want to take height and then
we want to take weight okay
and then we are going to calculate bmi
now so and then we are going to also uh
thank the person based on the bmi um so
the first thing that we need to do is uh
let's get the bmi calculation bmi
formula
let's say
and then okay basically it is
weight divided by height square
and the height should be in kilograms uh
the weight should be in kilograms and
the height should be in meters so what
we can do is we can say
okay first let's do the formula and then
we can we can have a description so bmi
is equal to bmi val is equal to
height
weight divided by height
square
okay
use the parenthesis so that you don't
have confusion about anything so now
that at this step we are calculating bmi
so we're going to say
print
and then we're going to say hello
and
the name of the person
which is in this case is name
plus
something
and a new line
and your bmi is
and then
you're going to say str of
bmi well
okay let's run the function oh i didn't
return anything right so i should have
ideally returned this return this
let's run this
and then try to give the value so i'm
going to say one little coder
and the value which is 20
120
and then
weight is like let's say 15 and the bmi
is 0.334 i have definitely messed up
this formula
which is kilogram weight divided by
height square and height should be in
meters
right height should be in meters in the
sense
um one point
centimeters okay 1.2 maybe
yeah so we have got a bmi so
approximately our formula works fine so
bmi part is done so the next important
step for us to do is so make sure that
you have three inputs
and you have one output right so if you
want two outputs we can still do that
but right now we are exploring only one
output so what we're going to do now is
we're going to say okay
interface
is equal to
gradient interface
of
and then we're going to say
function is equal to bmi that that part
is simple
inputs is equal to what are the inputs
we want the first thing that we want is
a text input
the second thing we want is a check box
um the second thing is let's say in this
case
uh slider maybe gr dot inputs dot slider
and the slider value goes from 0 to
let's say 100 and the label if you want
to add a label say height
okay and then you are going to have
another slider
and this slider is for
weight
in
kg
and height in
meters okay
and
this should be actually 200 i think yeah
now this is done the next thing is we
need to define the output
and the output in this case is a simple
text we are not dealing with multiple
items so simple text should be fine
define this
it's worked now interface dot launch so
technically you can actually do launch
here also like if you want like if you
don't want to define the interface in a
separate step you can do that but yeah
just just um
for the sake of explicity i'm i'm just
doing it here
and then i'm going to launch it once we
launch it again the same thing happens
so it says link debugging is equal to
true like all the same examples so i've
got a name let's say name is one little
coder
and then height is somewhere like this
weight is somewhere like this
um weight in kilogram height is let's
say here
and then submit you can see that the bmi
has been calculated like forget about
what the formula is doing right now at
this point maybe what we can do is it
looks very ugly for us to show this
thing so maybe we can round it off then
we have to import okay i'm not not
dealing with rounding off at this point
so you have
hello the name bmi and then the value so
at this point you can see that we have
successfully managed to get three inputs
and then we are also outputting one
output but what if you suddenly think
okay instead of just having three inputs
let me have
one more extra output okay and now
probably that output is something like
um
as emoticon okay if the bmi is less than
this let's say there is an emoticon the
bm is greater than this let's say
another emoticon so
result emoticon emoticon is equal to
again for simplicity um
we we can we can use or i can i can
actually actually use this
okay so just use happy face
if
bmi val is less than
like maybe 30 i don't i don't know so
don't take health advice from this
otherwise
keep a sad face
how do i keep a sad face this is a sad
face okay this is a sad face
so now we have a result emoticon so now
what you can do is you can result this
emoticon as well as part of
this so we have
one
okay we have one entire string if you
want to make it easier you can see
output
string is equal to this okay
and then you have the emoticon so i'm
going to say output string
and then result
emoticon
and then i'm going to run this function
i'm going to call the function to c okay
so my my bmi is terrible so it's just
giving me this sad option
so now i can come back again and then
specify that my first output is a text
again i want to do text for the second
output as well like but if you want a
different output you can still do it but
in my case i want
a text output as well so run it
come back here launch it again
and once you launch it is going to give
you the application
and then you can see okay name is
let's let's say mars maybe
height and
okay just
now and wait is 58 something 16.
submit it
and then you can see
it's a happy face the reason we have a
happy face is primarily because
the bmi is less than 30. so if i go back
to the same example like for example i
should be in meters right um
i should have ideally divided this
because height is in centimeters
let me add centimeters and then divide
the height
by
two
okay i hide by hundred
okay run this
and then try the code
run this
try the code
what am i getting
okay it's because of order of precedence
my code is getting messier with all the
parentheses but that's okay
so now i have defined height in
centimeters weight in kilograms and come
back and launch it again
then maybe this time we can say
mars and jupiter are the names
height in centimeters okay i didn't give
centimeters
it didn't get updated with this okay
submitted
okay the app did not refresh one last
time
let's refresh this
launch it
and
hide in centimeters yeah
one little
quarter height in centimeters
160 and then when you say bmi is 32 and
you're sad and your bm is less
okay you're still sad
okay let's reduce the weight
and then ideally now you're happy
because your bm is less than 30. so
technically we have managed to build an
application
with two outputs again if you want to
change the
um the name of the output again that's
something that you can change within
your output as well so basically what we
have managed to do here is we have taken
multiple inputs and we have done
multiple outputs and
this is this is quite important because
in a lot of cases for example let's say
you are doing doing neural style
transfer usually for neural style
transfer you would have
multiple outputs sorry multiple inputs
and one output so you need to know how
to do multiple inputs and multiple
outputs and that's quite simple
you have to match the number of
arguments that you are getting in your
function with the number of inputs and
all you have to do is the type of input
so one of your input could be a slider
one of your input could be a text
another input could be a number another
input input could be an image so you can
you can have these multiple formats as
well it's not just you know like numbers
and all these things like for example
let's say like suddenly we are deciding
uh that we want to add a check box okay
and i want to i want to add something
new some that is um
feeling okay
and uh based on feeling i want to say
something okay so
we'll say
if
feeling
is true okay
then uh then we'll do
text
is equal to happy
okay and we're going to send feeling
also
sorry text we have to send the text
okay now this one i'm going to make a
boolean out of it
okay
and
how do i make a boolean out of it or a
check box
so my last attribute here is
gr dot inputs dot check
delegate check box yes check box and you
can see when i want to make a check box
i have to specify default is false
right default is false and the label is
your feeling today
and then
everything else is fine so we have the
text as well so we have a third text
run it
run the function again
and then launch it
now at this point technically
you should have one extra check box so
check box is selected
something something
height
weight
selected
there is an error
there is an error and what is the error
okay so we have got
three inputs one
two three four i had four inputs
one two three four
okay i think the problem is because
if
okay let me
let me even do this
text is equal to if
feeling
else sad okay
and let me
run this
and then try with this
so we have one two three four one two
three four
okay that's done and then let's run this
let's launch
and
then let's see this thing so let's see
if we can if we can get rid of the error
it's successfully worked right so you
have output one output to output three
and then you can disable the feeling and
then run it again you gets had so
basically you've managed to add a new
type of input without any problem so you
have multiple types of input multiple
formats of input and also multiple
formats and types of output that this is
done so because we have got a bug maybe
this is a very good opportunity for us
to
try
try out the debugging option so what i'm
going to do is i'm going to make the
same mistake that we did before
and uh the mistake
was just using like this right so this
was a mistake that we had
and there is a way for you for us to
identify using this for example we can
we can do like this but if it is false
it would probably throw an error like
you can see the error but but let's
forget this kind of debugging for a
moment and then let's see
if we can find a way to debug here so
what i'm going to do is i'm going to say
debug is equal to true
and then launch it here
did it just say
okay sorry i have to add debug is equal
to launch so that was
silly of me i'm going to do debug is
equal to launch
when i do this thing
it's going to
launch with the debugging option okay so
it says this this cell will run
indefinitely so that you can see the
errors and logs so if you want to turn
it off again you have to go back and
then say debug is equal to false so what
we are going to do now is we are going
to say something
and then we are going to select some
value select some value and then click
so your your value is
good so you have got all the output the
problem arises when
you have false value and when you submit
now there is an error
okay so you can see that there is an
error now that error because we have
enabled debugging mode that error is
displayed here which wouldn't have been
displayed otherwise so now you can see
the error local variable takes reference
before assignment so which means saying
like it's the same error that you would
get when you are doing like like a
ripple or
interactive environment so this will
again help you to debug so i've just
taken the liberty of
making a mistake to explain you that um
that this is it so all i can do is i can
just add a nails or i can just go with
list comprehension
then fix this
come back again in debugging mode
right
come back again in debugging mode do
interface
and you can see all these are not
running because this
launch is still running so i'm going to
stop it
everything is run and then run this
again
then try this out
but now the debugging mode is still true
so you have the modes set
true is happy done
and
false is error again because this
because because we we didn't run it so
ideally you understand the point the
point here is once you
once you once you have a mistake or a
bug an error it's very important for you
to debug it the same interface that you
don't want to you know juggle between a
lot of different interfaces so the
easiest option for you to do that is
debug is equal to true so once you do
debug is equal to true then you will be
able to debug the file so we'll have a
slightly extended debug session in the
next section uh but if you simply want
to debug this is your way to debug
so in this section we just learned
how to improve our radio web application
with multiple inputs multiple outputs
same format different format and we also
played around with a diff bunch of
options for us to see how it works and
we also made a deliberate mistake to
understand how do we go about debugging
so in the next section we will also
learn slight extension of how more to
debug or log what is happening there
this section we we're going to know a
little bit more about debugging your
gradio web application and also gradio
has a nice feature called flagging and
we're going to look more into that first
let's start with debugging in the
previous section at the end you might
have seen that we try to debug so
extending that we're going to see what
kind of errors that we might face and
then some debugging options that we have
the first thing that you need to make
sure whenever you are building your
radio application is that
the function that you are using for your
radio application
the number of arguments in your function
should be equal to the number of
elements in your inputs and also the
number of arguments or number of items
that you are returning should be equal
to the number of items or elements in
your output so the first thing very
important that you need to make sure
that it is right the second thing is the
type of the argument for example here
name is a text make sure the input is
fixed
here if you have an output text again
make sure that it is an output text so
whatever the type is make sure it is
that type so that you know you know the
types have not messed up so because
because you are not going to compile
anything and check so it's always good
to have have this validation like if you
are bring creating a checklist of test
cases this is something that you should
do and let's say that you have you have
done all these things right and then you
have built an application but still if
you want to validate whether your
application has
any error then this is how you have to
debug it and the way if you want to
debug is basically you have to enable
debug is equal to
2.
so debug is equal to true is just a
function
like an extra argument that will help
you enable display error messages if you
want error messages to be displayed
while the radio application is run which
is like which is going to run without
stopping then you need the you need to
enable debugging like debug is equal to
true so let me quickly give you an
example and then we'll move on to the
next section
so if you see this thing for example
here we have got height and weight and
feeling right so
by default let's say if i don't have
debug is equal to true okay i have this
thing here i'm going to give some name
right and then i'm going to have
something here and if i submit
it worked but let's say if i keep it
like this and submit you see an error
now do you know why this error is
happening no of course you wouldn't know
why this error is happening even though
like probably if you're a
math whiz you would have probably
predicted it by this time but yeah let's
assume that you are an average
programmer so you don't know why the
error is happening and that's why it's
important for us to enable debugging
like this
and then after we do that so it says the
cell will indefinitely run like we saw
before so it's going to run all the time
so that you can try a lot of different
things and then you know have the error
log in place so now i'm going to do the
same thing i'm going to put the name and
then keep it 0 keep it 0 then submit
so it shows error the moment it shows
error it's going to also show the error
message and the error message here is 0
division error so float division error
so basically what has happened here is
that this is a thing that you wouldn't
have probably um
anticipated when you created this
application because now you're dividing
weight by height and then height cannot
be zero because you're going to get
divisible by zero error
and what is the ideal solution you can
you can go to your code you can change
everything you can handle the test
conditions or if you want to simply make
a change you can just come back here in
the slider you can start with one so
that your user can never go to zero
so run this
and run this
and
now again most likely you are starting
with one so even if somebody submits
something there is no way that they're
going to hit 0 in this case so this is
again a very typical example of how do
you find out an error and then fix an
error using radius debugging method so
if you want the debugging method to be
enabled and a lot of other things so
basically the same way you debug your
python programming code so you can debug
your gradient application in a very
similar way with debug is equal to true
enabled while you are launching the
application
now that is set so the other important
thing that i just talked about is flag
i just told the start of the section
that flag is another very interesting
case so what is flag the flag is a
button that helps you flag any
erroneous or unexpected behavior in the
output so you could be running a model
and then suddenly you see something
weird you can use flag you could um you
could have like let's say my
segmentation model and then you're
trying to find out which images have
done well which images have not done
well so you can just click flag whenever
you see the images have not done well
and you could you could use this for a
lot of purpose but what happens when you
click flag that's the most important
question right let's say you have an
internal machine learning team and you
have created an application and given it
to them and that team whenever they find
out something weird some
let's say some bias some
something
unexpected happening in the model
behavior or even in this calculation
something weird is happening right so
now we want to
flag the team that has created this
application so what does it mean what
does the team see when we create flag
here so let's do a couple of flags and
i'll let you know so first there is a
flag so let's do one more thing
and then we'll say
um another flag okay so we have flagged
at this point we have flagged two items
in this case so now what happens here is
when you create flag uh ideally there is
a flag folder that gets created so i've
stopped it and then if i go back there
is a flagged folder so when we go to the
folders let me refresh the folder and
you can see there is a flagged folder
and there is a log here let me copy the
path of this folder come back here and
then use pandas to show you what is
there import pandas as pd
pd dot underscore csv in the path
and then you can see the instances
you can see the instances what is the
name what are the inputs that were given
and what was the output and these are
flagged so this is to help the machine
learning team
our ml ops team whatever the team that
is going to look into the model issues
to check
what are the items that are flagged by
the users or internal testing or
whatever that is right so whenever you
flag something there is a new entry that
is made here and
and that entry is used in the future to
evaluate the model or the performance of
the application so right now what you
saw is an application
that just had text
so now what happens when you have images
what happens when you have images right
for example we had we had an application
like this what happens when you have an
image like this when you have an
application that has images both the
input and output images get stored
unlike this where you have text where
you have everything in tabular data only
and you didn't have anything else right
so if you go to the folder you wouldn't
see anything else other than dot csv but
when you have images the actual images
are any other media type for that matter
the actual media content itself is
stored inside that folders making it
easier for you to
evaluate what has gone wrong
this is a very important aspect um again
when you are going to use gradio for
iterating your machine learning model or
improving your machine learning model
this is quite important and useful to
use and again a lot of people who build
radio might not be very aware of this
thing because you know just exist there
but yeah efficiently using flag can
improve your machine learning model can
help you identify
there is a bias like for example let's
say you put together a machine learning
model and then you have created a radio
web application you have a published
return hugging spaces or somewhere
you can explicitly tell your users
saying that if you find anything
interesting weird
then please go ahead and click flag
because that will help us improve the
model eliminate the biases or you know
um be more robust so you can tell this
explicitly in the description like you
have a description right like you you
can like you can write a description
here like this
and then
flag if you find any
erroneous
output okay so i can run this and then i
can let me disable it and then it can
run when it runs
it will the description flag any flag if
you find any erroneous output so having
this message very clearly as part of the
application
could help people understand that when
they see something wrong they have to
flag and that comes to you as a very
well structured data which you can use
in the future to fix your machine
learning model or do anything that you
want to do with the data so one aspect
of
debugging and radio is actually you know
using the debug is equal to true but i'm
also including this in this section
because i believe that if you have a
machine learning model doesn't work well
if your machine learning model is doing
something semantically wrong not
syntactically but semantically wrong
only the user who is actually seeing the
output can tell you that thing and that
human intervention could be made the
flag could be raised using this flag
button and that could be extremely
useful in a lot of different cases
one thing that you would want to note
when you're talking about flaggers
um so right now the flag content is in
the
the actual um folder like the current
folder but if you want it to be in a
different folder then you have a
flagging directory so you can have a
separate directory you can specify a
separate flagging directory and that
will probably enable you to
have this flagging like flagged content
in a different directory altogether if
you wanted to in a different directory
but otherwise everything is good here
flagging is extremely helpful this is
how you do it debugging and
these are some things that you should
pay more attention to
and in the next section we will learn
some quirks and nuances about
gradient application
so far
we have learned all basic and very
important things about building a radio
application so in this section we are
going to learn how to enhance or improve
your existing radio application that
looks better that does better it has
better user experience and to start with
we are going to talk about examples in
radio application so what is examples
for example if you have a radio
application that looks like this
sometimes the user might get confused
what do i have to give here what do i
have to do here what do i have to do
here
and to avoid this confusion usually in
user experience if you see a lot of
existing tools like i can quickly show
you a tool that i came across recently
which is called shell.how when you go
here
it's still loading but when you see this
thing you can see there are suggested
commands so these are like examples so
instead of somebody trying to figure out
what to type here a good user experience
would
always be very intuitive where people
can just click it and then select it in
a very similar user experience principle
radio also has got something called
examples and i am going to show you how
to do examples in this section right now
so let's start with the example an
example is quite easy what do you want
to do with example for all the input you
are going to give an example value so
i'm going to come here and then say
after outputs i'm going to say examples
okay and here i'm going to just
i'm going to select what all examples
i'm going to give there like they the
predef examples are nothing but
predefined answers so i'm going to have
a list and within that i'm going to have
another one and the first one is let's
say one little quota name
and then the second one is let's say 100
um and then the third one is let's say
50 and then the fourth one is true okay
so this is one example the next one i'm
going to copy let's say mars
120
30 20 yeah and third example like we
will stick to three examples let's say
moon
and then 200
or maybe we can use even moon
and then third one
50 kilos
and then false so we have three examples
now when we run this application
oh
invalid syntax
because we didn't add the comma there
that's why it's invalid syntax
when we launched this application
at this point you would see this
application being launched with examples
so you can see there are three examples
so when you have a gradient application
that looks like this
if you don't know let me even open this
gradient application separately so that
it's easier for us to see so when we
have this gradient application it might
be difficult at first for somebody to
uh know what to fill so what they can do
is we have examples all i have to do is
click this application and then submit
then they'll get the output click this
example click submit and then get the
output so it becomes very easy for
anybody to click something and then get
an output rather than themself typing
something so this is very important for
a very intuitive user experience and
thanks to gradio for offering this
because this is what a lot of good web
applications especially to give
intuitive user interfaces so whatever
the type is like if you have an image
you can give image as an example if you
have tabular data just like us like not
tabular data necessarily but text and
the numerical data and boolean values
you can have this so for whatever type
of data that you have you can specify
examples very simply just by defining
another parameter here that takes
different lists like you have multiple
lists multiple examples you don't want
to also give like 10 20 different
examples example should be like one or
two
in this case we have taken three
examples so example is a very very
important way for us to improve the user
experience of the radio application so
that is one important thing so you need
to know when to use example and how to
use example and that's what you just
learned the second thing is what if you
don't want to click submit all the time
what if you wanted to build reactive so
if you have seen streamlight if you have
seen r shiny or if you have seen even
tableau like there are a couple of
instances where you can select an option
and then suddenly it is reactive so
suddenly you would see the output rather
than somebody going and clicking and for
that
within this like within the gradient
interface you have an argument called
live
if you say live is equal to true
currently by default life is equal to
false if you say life is equal to true
then you don't have to submit every time
and that's what we're going to see now
i'm going to disable the exam okay let
me keep the examples
and say
life
is equal to
true
right and then let's run it
and let's run it again
is it going to restart i'm not sure
because that's okay
so i have this thing here right i have
this thing here but you can see that
there is no submit button at this point
so submit button is gone because it's
live so all i have to do is i can go
here and then select it and then you can
see the output i have to go here and let
me zoom out a little bit yeah all i have
to do is go here select it you can see
the output
i can go here select it you can see the
output select it you can see the output
so basically you are eliminating one
extra step so this is useful in some
situations not in some situations for
example if you have a situation where a
model inference takes a lot of time then
you wouldn't want this to happen because
if somebody like
by mistake click something still you
know it would start processing so you
would want that explicit submit button
in those kind of cases in cases where
you lit for example this case right we
don't necessarily want somebody to click
submit
in cases like this you can like for
example you change the slider it would
it would change so
in cases like this this makes sense but
in some other cases it may not make
sense but live radio application is
another useful feature because it again
improves user experience where a submit
explicit submit action button action is
not required so if you think an explicit
action like submit is not required
then you can um then then you can
actually have
then then you can actually have this
thing in place um which is a live
application so the next way to improve
user experience is
we discussed in the previous section
about flagging
so
flagging can also have multiple options
for example instead of just simple
flagging we can say flagging options
so we can say yes
no
maybe something like that
okay and then run it
and run it and now when you run this
thing
you can actually see flagging options so
you instead of like for example let me
click this thing and you have three
flagging options all you have to do is
hover your mouse on it you have three
flagging options
so yes no maybe and these thing these
values might also get recorded so
flagging again instead of keeping a
simple flag for example let's say you
want to build a text annotation
um some like simple annotation tool so
now all you have to do is like you can
have all your entities here and then you
can ask somebody to annotate so as
simple as that even if you have image or
whatever that is or maybe like a
prediction is right or wrong or not
right so you can again use this to
actually
do your unit testing and the flag flag
not only when something is wrong but
also you can use this to
kind of label things
on the go while you are building your
machine learning model again flagging
options is extremely helpful
because you can use it for something
more than what flagging is supposed to
do
so flagging is very very helpful so far
we have seen examples so far we have
seen
live application and also we have we
have seen different options in flagging
the final thing that i wanted to
highlight here which i am not going to
show you right now
is using a state
so what is a state let me quickly show
you state here
radio
getting started
i'm going to copy the example from
gradio page
so
what is the state so one thing that you
know very clearly is that every time you
click submit in your gradio application
the entire app resets
that's i think that's something that we
all can agree there is no persistence of
data here so anytime you submit
something the data is reset
what if you want to have persistence of
data what if you want to use
a data point or a data from the previous
before submitting to the next instance
and that's where state comes into
picture and state is quite common again
in full stack development so if you want
to create a state that persists
outside of a single function call which
means you need a global variable right
so you need something that is outside
this function like outside the function
that you have this function if you want
if you have a use case like that
then you need to set state and the chat
message is a typical example right why
chat message is a typical example
somebody says hello and then you reply
hello and somebody says how are you
you're going to say i'm fine now in the
application you want all these messages
to be in there you don't want every time
to you know
initialize with empty message because
you want the previous data to be there
and that is where state is quite helpful
because you want the data to persist
across multiple submits
okay so let's look at this demo quickly
and then we can see
how it works
so quickly see the demo of state
i'm running this thing and again like i
said before this is an example straight
out of grade your documentation so
message is hello and i'm going to submit
it you can say hello don't know so it
says the next message is how are you
and then i can see how are you okay so
you can see the response you can see the
response here right so
and this is important because you want
the message to persist as well so that's
why state is very important and uh you
can refer grade your doc i'm not getting
deep into it because that is again um a
topic for a separate uh you know section
altogether so to avoid that i'm just
saying that you can go to the get
started page and graduate also you can
check in the documentation about state
so this is what the purpose of status to
have something beyond the function like
to create like a global variable outside
the function call so that even when you
when you load this thing
um it doesn't there is persistence and
the very best use case that you can
think of is you want to load a large
model and every time you want to load
the model you don't want it to be
refreshed if you have if you have the
model being loaded inside this you don't
want it to get refreshed all the time so
you want to load the model outside the
function and then inside the function
you do everything else like inference
right so
so that is a very good use case and
states could be used there so explore
state more and that could be really
really helpful for you in improving your
gradio application so if you need a
variable that should be persistent
outside the function call then
set state is the function that you
should set state and git state is a
function that you should be looking at
to store and retrieve the persistent
data that you have created so that is
state and the final
this is state then so we have seen
examples we have seen live radio
and we have seen state and the very
final thing that i want to talk about
improving your radio application is
grade your themes and grade your css so
gradual application by default you would
see something that looks like this i'm
going to remove
i'm going to remove the flagging options
i'm going to remove the description
i'm going to even remove the live option
okay so by default you would see the
gradient application that looks orangish
which is in line with the gradient color
but um but sometimes you want something
else right so sometimes you want to
you want to try something else like you
want a different color combination you
want a different theme so gradio has two
options for that for you one gradient
has got theme so quickly showing theme
so you have the default option you have
hugging face option you have grass
option peach option dark option so you
have got
different themes the second one is
rather than using the existing theme the
theme that is available on all these
themes you yourself can actually create
custom css so you can use custom css
option to create scene
and that is again another important
feature if you want to try out something
so we're going to explore these two
options now so theme and custom css
first let's start with theme so i have a
gradient application that looks like
this and
maybe you know what i can
i can do side by side oh it doesn't it
doesn't let me do side by side
okay i thought i can just show it side
by side
it doesn't allow me to do that view
that's okay so
first thing that i want to do is i want
to enable a theme okay so team of
theme is equal to
what is the theme name
let's start with the hugging face and
then we'll go to some dark theme when i
run this thing
and run this you would see the theme
color changing
it's you can see now the theme has
changed like it's in
this is the hugging phase theme
right so it's cleaner means i would
actually say like it's cleaner if you
want no no offense to existing default
radio theme but yeah it's it's cleaner
if you want a different theme let's say
like you want a dark theme then you can
just go like dark
peach or dark default maybe we can do
dark hugging face let's let's try how it
looks
dark
okay run this and run this
and then see how does it look
oh this is quite nice this is again a
very pleasant dark theme so you can you
can see the font is white in color you
select something you submit something
you have everything in white and color
so this way you can play around with the
theme
right hugging face thing let us say you
have played around with this thing but
there is one thing that you don't like
necessarily
and you want to change that and that's
where your css is going to help so one
thing that you can do with css is you
can for example let's say you want to
change the background color to something
so i can go here say css is equal to and
then i can i can add the css i'm going
to use
multi lines just to keep it easy for me
and then i'm going to say background
color
is
great
okay let's run this
run this
and then you would see the change in the
color ideally
i didn't change okay let me disable the
theme
and then see
[Music]
you can see after i disable the theme
because the theme overwrites the css so
after you disable the theme you can see
the color of the background has changed
like if you want let's say like a
different color altogether let's say you
want
you want let's say
yellow maybe terrible option but again
just for demo purposes
if you want a background color to be
yellow in color you can you can again
change it
in the previous section we learned how
to improve the user interface and user
experience of our gradio web application
so we learned about examples we learned
about live mode we also learned a little
bit about state and then finally we
learned about themes and css custom css
to redesign our gradient web application
in this section we are going to learn
how to share the gradio application with
anybody in the world and also the most
important aspect is do you want
everybody to see that or do you want to
add an authentication page before
anybody could access your gradio
application so the first thing is by
default when you launch your greedy
application you would get a url like
this and that that url stays for 72
hours so you can get this url and then
share it with everybody anybody in the
world and then they can use the url for
72 hours but if you want to make it
explicit there is an attribute called
share
so if i say share is equal to true
whether to create a publicly shareable
link from your interface so you can say
share is equal to true and that will
also give you the same url if you want
and then the next thing is
you don't have to only share the app but
also you have the ability to share the
apa which is something that not again a
lot of people would do so apas are very
helpful for example if you want to
integrate this let's say you have a
javascript based stack available and you
want to integrate this machine learning
solution inside javascript based
solution the easiest way for you to do
is to use an apa so what gradeo also
gives you is the apa with also some
starter code so for example the
for this particular app when i click
this view the apa you can see that there
is an api here and then that api says
like this interface takes four inputs
returns three outputs the url endpoint
you can copy and these are the input
types these are the output types this is
how the payload is going to look like
and this is how your response is going
to be and also you have couple of
examples where you have a python code
you have a curl code and you have a
javascript code so if you want to check
it you can go here and then click post
and then you would get the response
yours help
or if you want to try it on your google
collab as well you can come back here
and this and then see okay
okay true
we have to say true
and then see you have the
output so the time it took the data
input and sorry the data output and then
again the time it took so if you have
multiple calls then you can see the
average time otherwise it would mean the
same so basically not just the app that
you can share with the world but you can
also share the api where anybody can
make a call to the endpoint and then get
the result that they want uh instead of
saying get the result i should say
post the
response
post the request then get the
response
yeah whatever it is so
one
take this link
share the link with anybody they would
be able to access the app second
add slash api or the api link that you
can get from here and then share it with
anybody they can use it the second now
that we know how to share a gradient
application with the entire world
the next important thing is do you want
to share it just like that or you want
to share it with an authentication page
so now we are going to learn
how to add an authentication page on top
of our gradient application so basically
when somebody clicks this link let me
show you this link so basically when
somebody clicks this link we don't want
them to directly see this app like we
don't want anybody in the world to see
this app but we want only specific
people who have access to this
application so maybe let's say i have
generated a username and password and
given it to them i want only them to use
this application so if you want to add
an authentication page what are we going
to do and that is quite easy and simple
unexpectedly usually adding an
authentication page could be another
overhead but it is extremely simple here
because all you have to do is when
you're going to launch the application
all you have to do is you have to give
auth and also if you want any if you
want right only if you want any
html message on the authentication page
so i'm going to show you how it works
first let's start with an authentication
page a simple authentication page i'm
going to say auth
is equal to
i'm going to add a username password so
basically i'm going to do like this a
tuple username password and the username
here is let's say i'm going to say user
and then the password i'm going to say
is um one little code
okay so this is the username this is the
password okay i'm going to run this
after i run this thing
i've got the app so i'm going to click
the link here
and you can see it takes us to an
authentication page let's say i'm going
to give a wrong username password first
i'm going to say user and the password
i'm going to say something else
and when i do that it says the server
could not verify you you either supplied
a wrong credential or your browser
doesn't understand how to supply the
credential so
the first thing is
it works it works the authentication was
it's not letting anybody to login so now
let's try i'm going to give one little
coder
and then you can see it has successfully
taken us into the application so
basically we have managed to add an
authentication page on top of our
gradient ui
just purely with one single argument so
added a value username password to auth
argument and then we have managed to add
a login page
so let's refresh this
you can see this because we have already
authenticated so let's run this again
and i wanted to show you an extra thing
so when you run this thing when you go
here and see this thing you can see the
login page does not have much details
let's say you have shared the login
details to somebody in the email and you
want to make this
in the um
login page itself so that is where you
have an auth message so i can say auth
message
we can say check your
strong
login
details
strong
sent to your
email
so you can see email
and if you want to add add an emoticon
you can you can probably add an emoticon
so now you are adding a login message
also along with your authentication page
another like authentication message also
so
let me click this
go here and then see it says check your
login details into your email and you
have this thing so this way people would
know whether they have to look at their
slack channel or email or a discord or
whatever it is so that they actually
know where the email is once again let's
go let's just login
one little coder
and then try we have successfully
managed to login so this is how it is
quite easy and simple for you to add an
authentication page to your radio
application and
and it's quite simple so all you need to
do is you can give a tuple or also you
have another option so you can either
give like like username password tuple
or you can you can take different
formats out so like if you want or
you can have a function also like that
takes username and password and then you
know validate something and then returns
true if there is like the valid
authentication like let's say you have a
db you don't want to just give
hard-coded values then you can do all
those things and also you have the
ability to provide an authentication
message
along with
the login authentication page so this
basically takes us to the end of
building a gradient web application but
this course does not end here we want to
also deploy the gradient application so
for what we have done here is we have
managed to deploy the radio application
make it available on the collab
interface with gradual link but can you
deploy this radio application on
a permanent hosting and we are going to
see in the next section how to deploy
our gradient application using hugging
face spaces
this is the last section of this course
and if you have made till this section
congratulations you have almost done
something that nobody usually does
so in this final video we are going to
learn how to deploy a machine learning
radio application permanently on hugging
face spaces so the first question that
you might have is why couldn't we have
done whatever we were doing already as
something permanently so if you see this
thing this link whatever you share it is
applicable only for 72 hours
and the interface has to run so after 72
hours you may not get it then you have
to rerun it and then the url might
change you have a lot of these
complexities and to avoid that in a
typical permanent hosting space you need
a server where you want to host it and
hugging face the company the machine
learning company that used to be the nlp
company has made it really really easy
for anybody who uses gradeo or
streamlight to deploy very simply using
hugging face spaces so in this video i'm
going to show you how i've taken an
existing python script and then
translated into a gradual application
and then how are we going to deploy that
so the first thing if you see i am using
radio and transformers i am installing
both these libraries
and from
import radio sdr and from transformers
i'm importing pipeline transformers is
the hanging face library
pipeline is what we are going to use to
build a very simple sentiment analysis
tool so the pipeline name is sentiment
analysis because that is the task that
we are trying to do and after we do this
thing we are downloading all the
pre-trained models you can see the model
because we have not
specified any specific model it has been
defaulted to distilled bird base and
case fine tunisis to english it's
basically a fine-tuned version of
digital boot
after that we need an important function
so basically anything you want to do
with your gradient application you have
to wrap it around a function so here in
this case we are doing a very simple
function so the function name is git
sentiment and then it has an input text
and it returns as the sentiment output
the output would look like this
i'm not formatting the output here i'm
just leaving it out because i want it to
be simple for you to deploy the
application i don't want to take a lot
of time of you to modify whatever i'm
trying to do so it's going to be a very
simple gradient application so the
output is just a text that looks like
this
after that
our function is at this point ready so
get sentiment function is ready input is
ready and then the output is ready and
then we have also tested it right so i
can i can write something saying that
this course is super awesome okay so
that's my narcissistic view of this
course so it says it's positive it's 97
percent positive that's a good thing so
it's positive and 97
and whatever you want to do like for
example this
this course is
terrible
so probably it should say it's negative
will it yeah it says negative so
basically we have managed to build a
sentiment analysis solution using a deep
learning model which is distilled and
then with the just few lights of python
code thanks to hugging face now what we
have to do next is we have to take this
script the few lines of python code
and translate into a radio application
and for that we all know if you have
watched all the videos of this course
you would have probably known that we
are going to say gr dot interface
interface i with caps upper caps the
function name the input text we have
only one text and then the output text
we have another only one text as output
and also we have the title the title is
sentiment analysis we can also add a
description if you want we can say
um add
get
sentiment
negative
slash positive
for the given input okay so we have
managed to create the interface that
looks like this maybe
a better way is to do like this this
would increase readability but again i
don't know why am i spending time on
this thing but
maybe
okay so right now we have defined the
interface
with the object i phase now all we have
to do is launch i face let's see when we
launch i face
so again you don't have to do this on
collab you can do it on your local
machine and then then finally you know
connect it with your uh hugging face
pieces get and then upload it i don't
want to touch my local mission at this
point that's the whole reason i'm doing
this because i assume that a lot of
people might be trying to do this using
collab so that's why i want this
deployment experience to be how you
would do it on collab so
we have the title we have the
description we have the input text so
let's go ahead and then say this course
is freaking awesome and
and i love one little quarter words
that's
seriously
narcissistic but
i would take it still so it's a label
positive we have this thing again like i
said before we are not we are not
formatting the output so
just take text i'm throwing it just for
the demo purpose so now at this point
our sentiment analysis
application is up and ready now let's
see what we are going to do with hugging
face spaces
first go to google and then probably
say hugging face spaces
you would get this
you need to sign in if your hugging face
spaces have been recently
made open for everybody so it's out of
beta so if you
if you go if you have a hugging face
account you can log in with that if you
do not have you have to click create a
new account so i already have a hugging
face account so i'm going to use login
i'm going to use my username sorry
and then i'm going to use my password
and i'm trying to log in so this is how
my initial dashboard or my space
front page looks like so now we have to
create a new space so i'm going to
create click spaces
after i click spaces i can create new
space let me see if i can change
the theme the dark theme to light theme
you know i couldn't change
i hope it is readable for all of you so
click create new space
you can read the documentation if you
want you can read you know like what is
what you can do with the
stream return radio what kind of things
uh you can do how do you go about like
the best practices all these things
um so the good thing is all the models
that are available in hugging face
hugging face transformers are also
available for you here with a less
hassle so create a new space
after you create a new space we have to
give a space name so i'm going to call
it
gradio
sentiment
analyzer
is that a good name okay and the sdk
that we want to use is a gradient sdk
and you want it to be public or private
of course i'm happy to be
public so at this point you can see
there is no application file
your space when you open the app
it shows like there is nothing here so
you have to do certain things for
example you can clone this repository if
you are familiar with kit
you can clone this repository on your
local machine and then you can create a
simple app.pi file and then that app.pi
file can can you know so can be served
as an application
and after you create this on your local
machine then all you have to do is add
the file to your git commit the file and
then push it and then it would come here
to this particular folder and then your
app is available to be served but on the
other hand what we are going to do is we
are going to do everything on the
browser because like i said if somebody
wants to try it out just based on google
collab like you have already used google
collab your local mission is not
powerful enough you'd have you don't
know get you don't have rights to to get
if you are in any of these categories
then
proceeding section is for you so i'm
going to use the create button at the
last so let's open the create dot app
create app dot pi file the new
tab and then we have to copy our code
one by one so
you can copy one by one or in my case
i've already copied everything so i'm
going to paste so the first line is to
import radio the second line is to trans
like import pipeline from transformers
then we have the sentiment analysis
pipeline task and then we have the
function that uh helps us to get the
sentiment then we have the interface and
finally we have the launch and once we
have all this thing in place you can
specify launch
inline is equal to false
as well if you if you don't want it to
be in like usually you use inline is
equal to false
when you are going to avoid the app to
be embedded within your google column
notebook like if you wanted to be
launched separately so now at this point
everything is ready let's go ahead and
then commit the new file
we have successfully committed and you
can see it is trying to build but it
will end in a building error the reason
why it will in a building error is
because we have to install the
transformers library so even though
hugging face
spaces is actually on hugging face still
you have to manually install the
transformers library and also torch
which is a dependency for transformers
library before we install the library
right now there is an error that's
completely fine i just wanted to
highlight the readme so if you are using
this template by default you are sorted
out
but if you are not using this then then
you need to make sure that you have this
yaml at the top clearly because this is
what this is very important without this
part the yaml part on the top your app
would not be rendered properly on
hanging face so you have the title you
have the emoji you have the color and
you have the app file sdk and the app
file which is
actually used to create serve the
application so let's quickly go ahead
and then create a new
requirements.txt file requirements
dot txt oops
and then we need two things one we need
torch second thing we need transformers
so ideally we should be able to
so the first thing is they are going to
install these applications libraries and
after that they will render our app.phi
and our app.pipe because we have already
tested it should be successfully
running
let's see um you can you can never be
sure okay it says it's running so let's
copy this url go to a new tab and then
paste it oh
wait i think
i got a little excited you have to copy
the entire url
go back here paste it
and then see okay it has successfully
managed to work and also it has got the
dark theme that is
that goes well with the hanging face
dark theme that we have spaces so i'm
going to give an input text um probably
i think i'm tired of saying that this
course is awesome so maybe for a change
i'm going to say radio
is awesome and
i thank the developers
for this amazing tool
let's submit okay it's positive so maybe
i can say
java sucks
and then you have negative so you have
basically positive and negative and at
this point you have successfully managed
to build a full-fledged
machine learning deep learning powered
application deployed deep learning
powered gradient application and
successfully deployed it on hugging face
spaces now you can copy this link and
then give it to anybody if you if you
want anybody to use the api again you
have this thing also available for you
so you have successfully managed to
learn
everything from building a simple
gradient application to improving the ui
of the application and then finally
hosting or deploying your application
permanently on hugging face spaces
for free at this point i don't know
whether they'll charge us later but at
this point for free which you can share
it with anybody in the world thank you
so much congratulations
we have reached the end of this course
thank you so much for watching this
course and i hope you found this course
really valuable in learning how to build
a machine learning web application using
radio and also to deploy that
application you could use this for a lot
of different purposes as it is described
in the course and i would love to see
the radio application that you have
built during the course of this course
if you have any more questions please
let us know in the comment section you
can always reach out to us on twitter
and also please make sure that you
subscribe to our channel and share it
with your friends i wish you the best
for your machine learning journey happy
coding